السابق يتهم بوتين بتهديده
بالقتل بصاروخ.
اذا نشبت الحرب فلن تنجو اوروبا
وستدفع الثمن غاليا. روسيا تحضر
اسلحة متطورة ومرعبة للرد على
دبابات اوروبا والميدان
الاوكراني هو الحكم. لا تكتفي
بالدبابات وتطلب سلاحا اخر على
وجه السرعة. الاتحاد الاوروبي
يتحالف مع امريكا ضد الصين وبكين
تتمدد في الحديقة الخلفية
لامريكا. والزعيم الكوري يعلن عن
خليفته ماذا عن زوجته وشقيقته
والمقاومة الفلسطينية لقوات
الاحتلال? سنواصل عملياتنا ضدكم
فانتم اهداف مشروعة لنا. الكيان
الاسرائيلي يضرب ايران وزلزال
يضرب الاراضي السعودية وبين
العراق والمغرب. المياه تبدأ
بالعودة لمجاريها. رياح الحرب
العالمية تقترب. الكل يتحضر
والاصابع على الزناد. والعام لا
يزال في بدايته الروس يكثفون
ضرباتهم وغاراتهم على اوكران.
ليخرج الرئيس الاوكرانيسكي
مستنجدا بالغرب. تايلاند ان
اوكرانيا بحاجة الى صواريخ بعيدة
المدى من اجل ازالة ما سماه
بالارهاب الروسي. بينما تجري
محادثات عاجلة بين كييف وحلفائها
بشأن طلبات اوكرانيا الحصول على
صواريخ بعيدة المدى بحسب مستشار
الرئاسة الاوكراني ميخائيل لوبو
دولياك. اذا هل ستغامر اوروبا
وتدوس على خط بوتين الاحمر لترضي
زلنسكي وبعد قرار الغرب دعم
اوكرانيا باسلحة هجومية. ها هو
الرد ياتي سريعا من نائب رئيس
مجلس الامن الروسي ديميدري
ميدفيديف والذي قال ان توريد
الدبابات لاوكرانيا لن ينقذ
اوروبا اذا ما حرب عالمية ثالثة
مشيرا الى ان حماية اوكرانيا لن
تفيد احدا في اوروبا ولن تساعد
العالم القديم المتهالك في تجنب
العقاب ودفع الثمن. واضاف ان عدد
الحمقى في مؤسسات السلطة في
اوروبا لا يمكن ان يحصى لكثرته.
وهنا نعود الى كتاب المعارك
الاوكرانية. حيث تسابق روسيا
الزمن لتتصفح اوراق الكتاب ذلك
قبل دخول دبابات الغرب حيث
تغلغلت القوات الروسية في العمق
الاوكراني وبالتحديد باخموت
واوجلدار لاستباق وصول الدبابات
الغربية ما يضع كييف امام خيارين
لا ثالث لهما. اما مواصلة قتال
الشوارع الدموي وما له من كلفة
البشرية. ولا ننسى ان قوات فاغنر
تجيد باحترافية حرب الشوارع او
الخيار الاخر الانسحاب للحفاظ
على من جانبها نفت القوات
الاوكرانية ذلك كالعادة وقالت ان
الوضع في اوجليدار صعب ولكنه تحت
السيطرة. مضيفة انها تتصدى
لمحاولات تقدم القوات الروسية
وتكبدها خسائر كبيرة. لكن الجيش
الروسي يقول ان ما يعيق تقدم
قواته في مدينة اوجليدار ووجود
منطقة صناعية تستخدمها قوات كييف
كمواقع محصنة ليتكرر سيناريو
الحصار في مصنع في ماريوبل
ومناجم الملح في سوليدار. فهل
نشهد حصارا قاسيا للاوكران مرة
اخرى؟ نحن لم نرى رد موسكو
الحقيقي بعد يا سادة. فهناك سلاح
روسي مضاد لكل سلاح اوكراني وفق
هذه المعادلة تحاول موسكو الحفاظ
على اسبقيتها في الحرب
الاوكرانية. حيث كشر الروس عن
انيابهم باسلحة ومتطورة لرادعي
اي هجوم اوكراني بالاسلحة
الغربية في منطقة العمليات
العسكرية في اوكرانيا. حيث يتم
الان نشر منظومات ومروحيات وما
خفي كان اعظم يقولها الدب
الروسي. وفور رؤية اوكرانيا لتلك
الاستعدادات الروسية التي وصفها
الاوكران بالمرعبة ها هي تطلق
نداء استغاثة على لسان باسم سلاح
الجو الاوكراني الذي قال انهم
يسعون للحصول على اربع وعشرين
طائرة مقاتلة حديثة. لكن
المحادثات جارية ولا اخبار عن
تسليم اي طائرة لكييب. لننتقل
الى الولايات المتحدة. حيث يندلع
النقاش في البنتاجون حول التوريد
المحتمل لطائرات اف ستة عشر. لان
اوكرانيا تستعد لتنفيذ هجوم
الربيع لاستعادة اراضي وبرغم ذلك
يجري تدريب طيارين اوكران على
طائرات اف ستة عشر وفقا لصحيفة
بوليتيكو. الصين تحاصر امريكا.
تمضي الصين في طريقها في حين
تتقاطع طرقات خصومها ومع تصاعد
التوترات بين الغرب والصين يسير
الاتحاد الاوروبي على طريق
امريكا لحرمان الصين من الرقائق
الالكترونية المتطورة. هذا
الامريكي الاوروبي لمنع بكين من
الوصول الى اكثر التقنيات تقدما
وخلق صناعة اشباه الموصلات في
الصين وذلك بهدف ضمان الامن
التكنولوجي المشترك بين ضفتي
الاطلسي. فمن سيكسب ومن سيخسر?
اصحاب العيون الضيقة كالعادة لهم
الاسبقية بالرد. ولكن هذه المرة
في الحديقة الخلفية لامريكا
وتحديدا امريكا اللاتينية. تحولت
الصين الى الشريك الاول او
الثاني لكل دول امريكا اللاتينية
بفضل التبادل التجاري
والاستثمارات لا سيما في المناجم
والطاقة والقروض التي منحتها
بفوائد ضعيفة. نعم لقد تغلغلت
الصين في الحديقة الخلفية
للولايات المتحدة. ويعني ذلك
الاقتراب من الحدود الجغرافية
الامريكية. وهنا يكمن التحدي
المميت. اذا فكيف ان يؤمنوا
حديقتهم الخلفية بعد ان صارت
مرتعا للتنانين الصينية. خليفة
كيم جونج اون. ما يخفيه زعيم
كوريا الشمالية. لا يظهر للعلن
الا بامر منه. وكثيرة هي خبايا
هذا المجنون. هنا هذه الطفلة
المحبوبة لوالدها وهي التي لا
تزال في العاشرة من العمر اظهرها
كيم للعلن. وها هي بذراع والدها.
لكنها تتحضر للامساك بزمام
الامور في البلاد مستقبلا. نعم.
مجلة التايمز البريطانية تكشف عن
خليفة كيم جونج اون اخيرا.
وخليفته ليست الا ابنته جو ايه
في بلد يحترم الكثير من سكانه
مبادئ الكونفشيوسية والتي ترى في
الشيوخ اولى من الشباب بالمناصب
وتفضل سلطة الذكور اكبر من حكم
النساء. وبرغم ان شقيق الزعيم
كيم يو جونغ هي من اقرب الاشخاص
اليه وهي اقوى امرأة في البلاد
وهناك ايضا زوجته ريسولجو التي
ليست راضية عن شقيقة زوجها ليخرج
لهما المجنون ابنته وكأنه يقول
هيه هذه هي زعيمتكم من بعدي.
الزئير الفلسطيني يربك الكيان.
العين بالعين والبادئ اظلم. هكذا
اعلنتها المقاومة الفلسطينية.
وبعد عملية القدس عادت مجموعة
عرين الاسود الفلسطينية لتؤكد
مواصلة القتال ضد الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي وتنفيذ عمليات اطلاق
نار على اهداف اسرائيلية في
المنطقة. هذه المجموعة تتحصن في
البلدة القديمة لنابلس وتضم
عشرات المقاتلين الذين لا ينتمون
الى اي من الفصائل الفلسطينية.
لتتلقى تل ابيب ضربة اخرى. وها
هو المندوب لدى الامم المتحدة
يقول انه يجب على اسرائيل
الامتناع عن استخدام المزيد من
العنف وحماية المدنيين وفقا
للقانون الدولي. مضيفا ان مجلس
الامن غير قادر على ايصال رسالة
قوية بشأن القضية الفلسطينية.
لتنفس اسرائيل عن غضبها. لكن في
ايران حيث نفذت هجوما بطائرات
مسيرة على منشآت عسكرية تابعة
لوزارة الايرانية بحسب صحيفة وول
ستريت جورنال. الاحداث
والتطورات. هزة ارضية تضرب جازان
بالسعودية ووسائل الاعلام
السعودي تبث فيديو يوثق اهتزاز
بعض المنافع. بعد ان تم حظر
السلاح عن تركيا صنعته واصبحت هي
القوة الحادية عشرة في العالم
والاولى في الشرق الاوسط لتصبح
قوة مستقلة لا يمكن تجاوزها.
المغرب يعيد فتح سفارته في بغداد
بعد ثمانية عشر عاما من الاغلاق.
خلال مراسم تشييعه المدبرة
مسبقا. برازيلي يخرج من تابوته
اثناء البكاء عليه وسط صدمة من
اصدقائه واقاربه والسبب غريب.
نعم فقط من اجل ان يعرف من سيحضر
وفاته. روسيا لا تظهر اسلحتها
عبثا. ومع كل سلاح تظهره
اوكرانيا يظهر الروس ما هو اقوى
منه. فما الذي سيظهره الروس ان
وصلت الطائرات